I am consenting to have sex today on
camera pretty much in my psychiatrist I
might be doing it naked but I'm making a
difference so one for people to do this
job you won't have your porn
[Music]
we can't ignore that porn today is sex
education I want to show sex which is
much more emotional I literally can't
stop looking at that screen I'm in a
room full of 300 people but I'm on my
phone so technically like I'm alone from
camming I get a kind of relationship
that I have trouble with in real life
[Music]
the same people who are judging you are
the same people who consume your
problems
we have become so selfish
and I think a large part of that is due
to social media from me being 40 years
old this is completely unacceptable
behavior
I feel I'm a feminist women on the other
side of the camera are great
you deserve some real happiness not just
the computer fantasy my dad is never
gonna be okay with what I do of all the
decisions I've made this is my best one
[Music]
[Applause]
you